- Last semester of college I
was, like, well this is it.
- College isn't about being popular.
It's about being yourself
and finding people
who wouldn't want you to be anyone else.
- Spend time building those relationships,
'cause as an adult you
have to try really hard.
- Join as many clubs as possible,
because you're not going to have
an opportunity like
that outside of college.
- This is the time where you can explore
and discover your sexuality.
Just be safe.
- I wish I knew in college
to take more classes
that I'm curious and interested in.
- And the more you take
your time for yourself
you'll discover what you want to do
and where you want to go in life.
- Do everything you can
in those four years.
And if you take five, don't feel bad.
- Definitely do internships in college.
Do ten if you can.
- If you graduate with a certain
degree or a certain major,
it doesn't necessarily mean
that you have to go into that field.
- Don't be afraid to have
crazy, ambitious career goals.
Because if you don't dream,
then no one else is
going to dream for you.
- Sometimes in college, you
want people to be a certain way,
so you try to change people.
- You have to try and let
go of that negative energy,
and just keep the people in your life
who are really adding to
it not detracting from it.
- Talk it out.
Even though it sucks.
Because the sooner you talk about it,
the sooner the problem's done
and then you can focus on other things.
- Just take a deep breath,
because there's gonna be a
lot bigger things in life
that you're gonna have to worry about.
- College is not just about
finding what you're good at career wise,
it's also about finding yourself.
When people ask you what
your experience was,
share it.
- Something that I really
got out of college was
making life long friends.
Cause those'll be the people
that will be attending
your wedding in the future.
And that'll be there when you need help.
- Don't compromise yourself at your core.
Kind of stick to your guns
and stay true to yourself.
That's the most important thing.
- If there's something you want to do
and you even have a slither of doubt,
just do everything possible
because you're not going
to have this chance again.
- Taking things as they come.
There is no rule book.
There is no set plan.
Whatever you think is necessary,
just do you.